THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, IN PAST PROGRAMS
HERE AND ELSEWHERE, I PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE PUTIN WING
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, I
PUSHED BACK AGAINST THE
PUTIN WING OF MEDIA.
OF THE APPEASEMENT.
THE EXCESSIVE BRANCH OF
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES,
OUR TRULY LOUSY GENERALS AT
PENTAGON AND OTHERS IT IS
CLEAR WHEN VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAD ALMOST 200 THOUSAND OF
HIS MEN LINED UP ON BORDERS
WITH UKRAINE, HE INTENDED TO
INVADE, PEOPLE RAISED DOUBT.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE,
500 TANKS, HE INTENTED TO
INVADE, THAT IS THE TIME AND
BEFORE THAT.
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO ARM
UP THE UKRAINIANS, NOT THREE
OUR FIVE WEEKS LATER.
WE ALL KNEW AFTER THE
DISASTER OF AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT WAS COMING.
WE ALL KNEW WHEN BIDEN WAS
APPEASING PUTIN IN EVERY
WAY.
WHETHER A PIPELINE OR
NUCLEAR DEAL, WE KNEW THIS
DAY WOULD COME, WE KNOW THAT
COMMUNIST CHINA AND XI,
ANOTHER PSYCHOPATH MANIAC
HAS EVERY INTENTION OF
INVADING TAIWAN, WE KNEW IN
TERRAIN, THE ISLAMIC REGIME
THERE, DANGEROUS, NEO-NAZI
REGIME TEHRAN WOULD
CONTINUE TO BUILD NUKES TO
ATTACK ISRAEL, AND EVEN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IF WE KNEW THIS, HOW IS IT
THIS BIDEN DIDN'T?
HOW IS THIS SECRETARY OF
STATE AND SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE DID NOT?
WELL I SUGGEST THEY KNEW IT.
THEY ARE WEAK.
AND PATHETIC.
NOW WHAT?
WELL, PEOPLE WANT COMPUTER
PUTIN TO DECIDE WHAT THE
BATTLEFIELD SHOULD LOOK
LIKE.
THEY SHAKE.
NOW LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, AS
I HAVE SAID BEFORE, OLD
SOVIET UNION HAD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, RUSSIA HAS HAD
NUCLEAR WEAPONS FOR A HALF
SENSE WE
HAVE THEM TOO, WE CANNOT
ALLOW NUCLEAR BLACKMAIL TO
DETERMINE THE FATE OF THE
WORLD OR FATE OF UNITED
STATES VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL
NOT USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS, NOT
NOW.
HOW DO I KNOW THIS?
IT IS COMMON SENSE.
IF HE WANTED TO USE THEM, HE
WOULD.
WHY WOULD HE USE THEM IN
RESPONSE TO MiG 29S, OLD
JETS?
25 OR 30 OF THEM DELIVERED
TO THE UKRAINIANS?
BECAUSE IT MIGHT STALE
MIGHT, WE WERE JUST TOLD BY
OUR WHITE HOUSE AND ALL
PHONY EXPERTS ON TV IT WOULD
NOT MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
SO WHY WOULD VLADIMIR PUTIN
GO TO LEVEL ONE AND NEWS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN RESPONSE
TO MiG 29S, HE WOULD
NOT AND FURTHER MORE XI,
WE'RE MORE POWERFUL THAN
CHINA RIGHT NOW.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE STAY THAT
WAY, EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
SLIDING AS A RESULT IN
PARTICULARLY THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WE NEED TO
MUSCLE UP OUR MILITARY NOW,
NOT WITH A FEW BILLION
DOLLARS BUT A SPECIAL
MANHATTAN-LIKE PROJECT, NOT
TO DID GO TO WAR BUT
PREVENT WAR, MAKE SURE WE'RE
THE MOST MUSCULAR MILITARY
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH,
THAT IS A DETERRENT, A
RESPONSE THAT IS PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH.
AS REAGAN AND TRUMP WOULD
PUT IT.
>> THEN WE HAVE NORTH KOREA,
IN A BOX, UNDER TRUMP,
NOW IT WANTS TO FIRE THE
SHINY BRAND NEW ICBM, BUT
MORE
CONCERN IS, RAIN,
ADMINISTRATION APPOINTED
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO NEGOTIATE
ON OUR BEHAVE WITH A REGIME
IN TEHRAN, THEY TALK ABOUT
DEATH TO AMERICA.
THEY ALREADY FIRED BALLISTIC
MISSILES AT OUR
CONSULATE.
WHAT IS OUR RESPONSE, IT
WAS A MISTAKE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING, PUTIN AND
NUKES, HE IS TRYING TO
CONTROL THE BATTLE FEEL BY
THREATENING US, YOU HEAR
ANALYSTS AND OTHERS SAY, WE
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THIS
WHAT DO YOU THINK IRAN WILL
DO?
IF IN A TOPPLE THE
GOVERNMENT IN EGYPT OR SAUDI
ARABIA, WE CAN'T DOE
ANYTHING BECAUSE IRAN HAS
NUKES.
ALL OVER THE WORLD THEY CAN
MAKE THREATS IT HAS TO BE
STOPPED.
YET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH PUTIN IS NEGOTIATING
A DEAL THAT IS WEAKER
THAN DEAL OF 2015, GIVING
TENS OF BILLIONS TO THE
IRANIAN REGIME WITHOUT
RESTRICTION, ENSURING THEY
HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS, ON
ICBMS,.
THAT COULD REACH ANY CORNER
OF THE EARTH, IT WILL ENSURE
THAT TERRORISTS WHO RIGHT
NOW ON TERRORIST WATCH
LISTS, WILL BE REMOVED, THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN GUARD, REPUBLICAN
GUARD THAT SHOT THE MIFERLS
MISSILES AT OUR CONSULATE.
THEY CREATED CASUALTIES,
MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE.
HAVE LOST LIMBS, HAVE BRAIN
INJURIES AS A RESULT OF
IRANIAN REPUBLICAN GUARD AND
OTHER TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE DONE,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, JOE
BIDEN IS GOING TO UNLEASH A
NUCLEAR COMPETITION WHERE
THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES WILL
HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
THERE WILL BE EASIER AND
EASIER TO GET.
AND HARDER AND HARDER TO
CONTROL.
THAT MIGHT WIND UP IN HANDS
OF TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS.
IF WE DO NOT PUT AN END TO
THIS.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH, NOT
PEACE THROUGH APPEASEMENT OR
STUPIDITY, THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
THE IRAN THING IS NOT
GETTING THE ATTENTION IT
DESERVES, A YOU CAN WEEKS
AGO WE HAVE EXPERT FROM HER
HERITAGE FOUNDATION,
HE SAID YOU CANNOT BY --
BIFURCATE RUSSIA FROM CHINA
OR CHINA FROM IRAN.
THEY ALL BACK EACH
OTHER, YOU BETTER BELIEVE
THEY ARE COLLUDING,
PARTICULARLY CAN A FECKLESS
PRESIDENT OF THE SORT WE
HAVE, VERY IMPORTANT WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, DESPITE THE
MOSTLY IGNORANT PART OF THE
MEDIA HERE, MOSTLY THE
INATTENTION OF MEDIA WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IS GOING ON
IN IRAN.
THAT IS WHY I WANT TO BRING
ON FORMER PRIME MINISTER OF
ISRAEL, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, AND ALSO DISCUSS
FURTHER RUSSIA AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES, AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN UKRAINE WIT